all right everybody here's the big
breaking news we got this from The Daily
Mail Utah man Craig deliu Robertson was
shot dead by the FBI in raid after
posting on Facebook a credible Joe Biden
death threat ahead of the president's
visit to Salt Lake City they say Craig
Robertson 75 was gunned down on his
doorstep by agents in Provo an hour from
Salt Lake City after they were alerted
to his spouse about the president
messages posted on what is believed to
be his Facebook page on Tuesday included
bloodthirsty content about how he would
I'm gonna I'm gonna be light on this one
but just let's see post and death
threats very serious stuff saying the
state would be famous for the actions he
would commit really really messed up
stuff now the commentary that we're
seeing from uh many on the right that
this guy is 300 pounds he's elderly he
can barely walk even with a cane and
wasn't a threat to anyone so I'm gonna
give you my immediate speculation in a
second but I want to say this first
you've got the left basically saying
this is the danger of the far right far
right extremists threatening the
president oh heavens help me you have
people on the right being like dude some
old fat guy posting on the Internet it's
ridiculous but the mo the the best uh
response that I've seen is
every single time someone threatened
Donald Trump nothing happened all of
these prominent leftists high-profile
individuals made death threats against
Donald Trump nothing happened Kathy
Griffin held up a a pic a a mock severed
head of the president nothing happened
this guy posts really awful things
nobody should be posting that stuff the
FBI immediately shows up to his house he
gets gunned down now here's what I think
I bet
you know they see these posts so they're
going to go and they're gonna knock on
his door and they're going to figure out
who he is what he's doing they're
probably gonna arrest him many people
have faced similar things I'm willing to
bet this guy showed up armed and that
was it
yeah he look I mean
first of all like there's no part of me
that's gonna defend this dude because
like you can't threaten to kill the
president
at all I just I think it's I think the
whole thing is funny because he's dead
because like it's dumb to threaten to
kill the president and then a was he
like 500 pounds or something people are
saying he was 300 pounds he could walk
75 years old but he's a big dude but
like when the cops come to your house
you don't need to like it's odd to get
into a gunfight with the cops like that
should be thought of as as a that should
be infrequent you know I I think this is
indicative of escalation because what I
think happens is sure this guy may not
be able to actually carry out any of the
things he's threatening because he's
morbidly obese and elderly but he
certainly had some kind of intent now
look Maybe I'm Wrong maybe the cops
showed up knocked on his door and he was
sitting in his couch you know covered in
Cheeto Dustin said hey look man I was
just posting nonsense and they were like
too bad and then shot him which I really
doubt yeah what likely happened is he
was angry and said oh you want to come
to my house over my you know you know
from my cold dead hands I bet he said
something about the freedom of speech
too get off off my property kind of
thing yup and then he was probably armed
because we know the dude had a bunch of
weapons and so
that this is this is this is what
happens but I will I will I will stress
did we get any raids when people were
threatening Donald Trump no I've heard
I've heard stories of people getting
their doors knocked down and guys being
like don't you do that I have a question
like um his posts were direct statements
that he was going to do something yeah
where the Kathy Griffin thing is more of
like no that I hope this guy dies well
hers hers was just her standing there
with a separate head what was that even
mean yeah uh have there were there
documented cases where people were
literally threatening to assassinate yes
yeah okay yeah there was there was a
dude who rushed the stage and tried
grabbing a weapon from a cop and and I'm
pretty sure that dude's still alive
there was that moment where the guy
rushed the stage and then Trump grabs
the podium spins around Secret Service
tackles him there was another moment
where a guy went to a theater and tried
grabbing a gun from a cop and they
fought him and stopped him and there
were tons of people posting threats on
social media and we're all sitting here
going like yo this is crazy these people
are losing their minds
so I think everybody's I I that's why
I'm saying escalation
because this guy may not be a threat but
yo
what is what is the saying those who say
don't know and those who know don't say
there are people out there who probably
feel the exact same way as this guy and
they ain't saying anything they're not
going to go on social media and post
about what they're going to do or what
their plans are we we don't and and this
is the the threat of complete and total
destabilization the best case scenario
is
the Republicans launch a massive ballot
harvesting operation
they utilize
ground activists to go door-to-door
Donald Trump wins in 2024 they clean up
the corruption they fire tons of people
there are criminal charges and trials
and that's it we move on the worst case
scenario in any capacity is anyone
escalating this to some kind of
high-level conflict
I don't know about high-level conflict
but I don't I don't I I definitely see
more escalation in the future right
you know I
I just don't people people need to
understand dude I still don't see the
off ramps you know I agree people need
to understand what life is like when
conflict conflict erupts and I think one
of the reasons why they're in history
there are stories of countries undergo
Revolution and that's it and there are
stories of countries that undergo Civil
War
and I think the issue is that for people
in these countries that face Revolution
things get so bad most people just say
whatever because I'm gonna I'm gonna try
and survive when Civil Wars break out
it's highly political and people are
like there's a better way to do things
if they fight each other over over the
way things need to be
my concern here is
it feels like either we enter some kind
of dystopian nightmare
or it turns into some kind of full-on
conflict
yeah I think with this particular
incident it's like Phil said it depends
on what happened when they showed up I
mean if we find out more if he started
shooting back at them right as they
showed up
I mean that's just kind of what you
expect to happen if you start shooting
at the FBI and
um especially if you're not able to yeah
but
um I mean I I do think the escalation
thing is a problem uh on your point
about you know the Republicans sweeping
all this corruption out
do you foresee that happening in any
capacity like because Christopher Ray
the FBI director he was appointed by
Trump and and predicating what Trump
will do based on what he did is a
mistake they betrayed Trump Trump's
angry and wants revenge so I expect
something different from him that being
said
I'm not gonna I'm not saying it's a high
probability or like the best probability
but who else are you gonna vote for yeah
it's like Rhonda Sanders ain't doing it
like if it's a 20 chance that Trump
would be success would successfully
clean out the government like that's way
better than any other anyone else that
would be I'm not good you know I'm not
gonna bet on Donald Trump being a good
dude who wants to save America a lot of
people are that's their bet my bet is
that they they betrayed Trump and Trump
Wants Revenge I think Trump won Trump
wanting revenge is something you can
count on yeah see I'm actually this this
is surprised a lot of people but I plan
to vote for Trump currently even though
I've been one of his largest critics for
how he handled lots of things uh but I
don't necessarily see him actually
fixing anything or
beheading you know figuratively
beheading a lot of his past uh
appointees
um I just think he's gonna drive people
crazy and that's enough for me like just
to drive the Liberals insane and make
everybody mad really gonna drive I don't
think the Deep state will let him win I
don't think they can't stop him well I
mean if they have proprietary voting
machines they can stop anyone they
didn't stop him in 2016. I know and they
made they realized their mistake and
then they stopped him and well he was
stopped in 2020 we should say I think
Republicans screwed up in 2020 I think
Republicans were in on it it was
Republican and legislatures in certain
States who are passing these Universal
uh mail and voting laws in Pennsylvania
they're the ones who helped Democrats
bypass their own Constitution so I'm not
worried about the Deep state I'm more
about the Republican party but I think
if Donald Trump and his supporters
recognize the threats when it comes to
uh these these these you know Shady or
illicit voting strategies which were
done legally by the way they're just I
call them Shady if they recognize that
and Trump seems to be Trump's going to
win and they know it and look I think
it's plainly obvious they would not be
indicting him unless it was possible for
Trump to win if they if they knew they
could control voting machines and they
can do all this they would not go
anywhere near Trump they'd be like oh
geez oh no here's trump it wouldn't
matter who ran they'd say please run get
all your supporters riled up no no they
are so desperate to stop him they're
talking about indicting him in Georgia
next week they are throwing everything
and the kitchen sink at him in a
desperate bid to stop him because
they're not confident they can yeah you
know the only person who can stop Trump
is Trump
biggest he's his biggest he's his own
biggest hindrance and I mean in 2020
regardless of all the things you're
talking about Trump trump was just he
was running an awful campaign in 2016 it
was great he was the new guy on the
Block he was anti-establishment he was
going to go in and kick everybody out
who was ruining the country in 2020 it
was kind of hard to make that claim
after he'd been in there four years and
everything was falling apart and we're
passing all these giant spending bills
so I think it's really on him if he
wants to win is to really you know
listen to his base and try to understand
what they're empathizing with them on
because over the last couple years he's
been a little bit off you know like he's
cheering on stuff that they didn't
support and he's even getting booed at
rallies occasionally and when he did his
CNN Town Hall I saw the old Trump kind
of come back when he was pushing back I
forget her name to the CNN
um interviewer there and he was making
all the jokes that he had made in 2016
he was talking about how we need to end
the war in Ukraine I was like okay this
is the 2016 Trump that can win an
election so I think it's really up to
him if he wants to win
I agree I I don't want to push my my
hopelessness on you but I there's
there's no way there's no way that will
not stop that guy there's no way it's
just funny that it's like in 2016 he won
and it's like he can't win it's
impossible but yeah but he he won
because they weren't expecting it they
made sure Bernie Sanders they weren't
expecting it though they propped him up
they thought he was going to lose to
Hillary they got rid of Bernie because
they wanted Hillary and they got easy
opponent and Trump and then they they
saw their mistake they're like we can
never make that mistake again with that
I I think anybody who's telling you that
Trump can't win is actively trying to
sabotage our path well anyone saying he
can win and and fire everybody and save
the world is also leading you down a
dark path yeah I completely disagree
yeah it is our only solution the FBI
just rated a guy's house who is sudden
death and they killed him the Solutions
in the private sector it's not these
politicians the solution to the
weaponization of government private
sector we need control of our social
Media communication technology you need
to be able to talk to your community and
and rally and organize and support it I
would I would agree on a cultural level
especially with Elon Musk buying Twitter
and then blocking government access to a
lot of the information that they've been
illegally I would say unconstitutionally
stealing
but we have got deeply corrupt
individuals who are weaponizing
government now the stories that I
introduced not even all of them the the
FBI was systematically going after
Catholics they're they're criminally
charging uh people who are walking on a
lawn in DC antifa is free to go in every
respect you've got story after Story of
death threats violence the left they're
getting away from it it is a
multi-faceted conflict I certainly
believe culture and yes to be fair
private sector is going to play an
outsized role in this but when it comes
to what is happening in government I am
specifically referring to how do we
solve direct short-term political
conflict and when you have people
threatening death what we need is
someone who's going to go in
fix the justice system in any way even
it means firing people and people who
keep saying no he can't win Trump can
never win I'm like dude you are you
might as well just go to El Salvador
right now because if you think
everything they're doing with
weaponizing the doj is unsolvable
because it's happening before our eyes
and they're going after they're going
after now Giuliani and Sydney Powell
Jeffrey Clark John Eastman if if you're
gonna sit back and say it is inevitable
it is hopeless then you should not be in
this country you should run you should
have run a long time ago oh no you can
acknowledge the Deep State and the power
they have over elections without being
black billed and giving up I mean but it
doesn't mean you got to bang your head
against the wall to create a hole like
there are other ways I think like Vivek
ramaswamy is a far superior candidate
and to act like Donald Trump's a better
vote because he's more popular I think
is is a mistake you should go for the
best candidate the the guy always go for
the best candidate that's how the best
candidate wins well see Trump is
actually my number three as far as
quality of candidate goes I actually
like are FK the most probably and then
probably
vivec and then Trump I'm gonna vote for
Trump just because he's going to cause
the most chaos and the most Anger from
people I hate that's honestly what I
care about I love how you think but what
you're you would go with RFK
before I mean there's a lot of issues
slightly
because I I because I'm I'm totally not
on the RFK yeah wagon I'm not either by
the way I'm not one man but like options
like I like the fact that he's counter
to like basically like the the official
narrative or absent or however you want
to talk about it but like all of his
past uh oh it's bad positions are awful
his position on the Second Amendment his
position on on climate change and and
what to do about it and and if it's you
know the amount of human uh input on
climate change and all that all that
kind of stuff all those things are
terrible like so I'm super not into the
RFK guy at all like I know the other
thing is a lot of Libertarians are have
bought into that and I'm just I'm I'm
I'm extremely apprehensive I I
completely understand the thing is uh
the the position he's running for the
things he's terrible on he doesn't have
much control over where the things he's
mostly good on on he would have a lot of
control over and the things that he's
good on that he'd have control over in
the executive I slightly prefer him to
Vivek and Trump thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time